hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
dr fauci is still in the news what is
wrong with you people
there have been a lot of um
theories and conspiracy theories and
accusations and more or less wild claims
about the origins of covet in particular
it seems like that's when um
people on the on the political right
really started getting their claws into
you and targeting you
personally um during this pandemic i
mean as a
as i said sort of a visible and singular
leader on infectious disease issues over
all these years you've you've faced
criticism sharp criticism before
it does feel a little different there is
a weird obsessive violent ongoing
demonization of you by the right that is
hinged on kovid i just have to ask from
your perspective if that kind of
attention that criticism feels
qualitatively different to you than
previous criticism if it is coming from
a different place if it is indeed more
dangerous than the kind of criticism
you've had in the past
right
rachel it's it's it's phenomenally 100
different it's it's apples and elephants
difference it really really is
back in the day
of hiv
and you showed some of those clips which
were quite quite accurate
what we were doing in the federal
government well we were being too rigid
and restrictive
in a disease that needed a great deal of
flexibility
and input
from the community the aids activists
that you saw
on the clips that you showed when you
examined what they were saying
and what they were asking for
they were entirely correct
so they opened our eyes my eyes
particularly which made me
actually turn into one of them
and an aids activist because we learned
from them and we learned that we were
being too rigid from a clinical trial
standpoint and from a regulatory
standpoint and the fda
modernized their approach based on that
too
what we're dealing with now
is just a a distortion of reality rachel
i mean conspiracy theories which don't
make any sense at all
pushing back on
sound public health measures
you know making it look like
trying to save lives is encroaching on
people's freedom
that's a big difference
from the aids activists who really had a
good foundation for their objections
having been the target of this kind of
really specific really different
attack do you have insight into what we
ought to do to protect public officials
like yourself and to to try to
be more rational about this stuff as a
country
you know rachel i wish i did have a
positive constructive answer for you
but i don't i think you and i are
talking about public health
issues right now
but what has spilled over
and really in many respects impeded
a proper response to a public health
challenge is something that we see that
goes well beyond
public health it's a complete distortion
of reality i mean
a world of where untruths have almost
become normalized how we can see
something
in front of our very eyes
and deny it's happening i mean that's
the environment
we're living in you could look at
january 6 on tv and you have some people
who actually don't believe it happened
how could that possibly be
and it's now spilling over
in denial about public health principles
so i wish i had an answer
uh but i don't i mean i i do have as
i've always been someone who is
cautiously optimistic and always feeling
that
we will be able to extract the good out
of people and there are
the possibility that we'll see
as i say the better angels in our
society prevail
but what's going on out there now with
the distortion of reality is very
troublesome
and i don't have an answer for it right
now but it certainly is interfering
with the proper approach to a public
health challenge